- Welcome to the Yale
Law School auditorium
and to Yale University.
It's a distinct honor today,
my name is Peter Salovey,
I'm the president of Yale,
and it's a distinct honor
to introduce our 2015 Chubb Fellow,
President Obama's national
security advisor, Susan E. Rice.
Ambassador Rice, we welcome
you to Yale University
and we're so grateful for your willingness
to share your time and your
insights with all of us.
We're delighted that Ambassador
Rice is joined today by
a member of her family who is
also a member of our family.
This is John Rice, Yale
College class of 1988.
And a current fellow of
the Yale Corporation.
Before I speak about our
visitors, I wanna say a few words
about the history of the Chubb Fellowship.
So Hendon Chubb was an 1895 graduate
of Yale's Sheffield Scientific School,
that's the precursor to the
Yale School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences.
In 1936, he made a substantial
gift to the Yale University
to encourage students to take
an interest in public service.
Since 1949, the Chubb
endowment has been used
to underwrite prestigious
visiting speakers
who would bring kind of
extraordinary presences to campus
that would inspire our students.
This fellowship is
administered by the master
of Timothy Dwight College, Mary Lui.
Past Chubb Fellows have
included four presidents
of the United States, presidents
of eight other countries
and more than 150 other regional, national
and internationally prominent individuals
noted for their distinction
in service to the common good.
The annual Chubb lecture
is a wonderful opportunity
to reinforce the shared
values of our community.
And I know it's a special
treat today for you all
to hear from someone who is serving
at the very heart of our nation
and our national interest.
As national security advisor,
Ambassador Rice oversees
the National Security Council staff,
chairs the National Security
Principles committee,
provides the president's daily
national security briefing
and is responsible for coordinating
the administration's foreign policy,
intelligence and military efforts.
She has held numerous appointments within
the national security
council, including as director
for international
organizations and peacekeeping,
as special assistant to President Clinton
and as senior director
for African affairs.
From 1997 to 2001, she was
the US assistant secretary
of state for African affairs, and in 2000,
she was co-recipient of the White House's
Samuel Nelson Drew Memorial Award
for distinguished
contributions to the formation
of peaceful cooperative
relationships between states.
As the senior advisor for
national security affairs
with the Obama for America campaign,
she went on to serve as a
member of the advisory board
for the Obama/Biden transition,
and then as co-chair
of its policy working
group on national security.
From 2002 to 2009, she was a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution,
where she focused
on US foreign policy,
transnational security threats,
weak states, global
poverty and development.
Before her appointment as
national security advisor in 2013,
she served as the US
permanent representative
to the United Nations, where she worked
to strengthen national and global security
and to promote human rights.
Ambassador Rice received her BA in history
from Stanford University.
She holds an MPhil and DPhil
in international relations
from New College at Oxford University.
And she was a Rhodes Scholar there.
This is a remarkable
opportunity for our students
not just to learn about
issues in national security,
but to learn about a career
path in public service
that I am sure is an inspiration.
I'm particularly pleased
that today's lecture
will actually take the
form of a conversation.
And it's a conversation
between Ambassador Rice
and as I hinted at earlier, a
member of the Yale community
who is uniquely positioned
to join her here on stage.
Why do I say that, well,
John Rice, Yale College '88,
and a fellow of the Yale
Corporation, is the founder
and CEO of Management
Leadership for Tomorrow,
which is a non-profit organization
that helps members of
underrepresented minority groups
to become leaders in the corporate,
non-profit and entrepreneurial sectors.
After graduating from Yale with a degree
in Latin American
studies, he earned his MBA
from the Harvard Business
School, and while at Harvard,
he wrote a business plan
for his current organization
and in 1994, he launched
it via a mentoring program
for minority undergraduates.
He was appointed to President
Obama's Advisory Commission
on Educational Excellence
for African Americans
and has served as a member
of the President's board
of advisors on historically
black colleges and universities.
He also serves on a number
of non-profit boards
including LIFT, the
National Center for Civil
and Human Rights, the American
Management Association,
the Woodrow Wilson National
Fellowship Foundation.
As I mentioned, he is a member
of the Yale Corporation,
the trustees of the Yale
University, our fiduciaries.
Before that, he was a member
of the University Council,
which is an advisory
group to the president.
But most importantly for today's purposes,
he holds a very special role and that is
he is Ambassador Rice's brother.
- Younger brother.
- So.
(audience laughter)
- So I would like you to
join me in thanking him
for facilitating today's conversation
and to also join me in extending
a very warm welcome to
Connecticut, to New Haven,
to Yale University, to
Ambassador Susan E. Rice.
- Thank you.
(applause)
I feel like I need a phone book.
Can you all see me?
(audience laughter)
Johnny got all the height in the family.
- She likes to say that
I'm the younger brother
because she feels that she looks younger.
So that's a side to that.
So thanks for having us, first of all.
And I think we're gonna
try to have some fun
over the course of the hour here.
And as Peter said, approach
this a little bit differently
than potentially some of the
past Chubb Fellow lectures.
What we'd like to do, and
again, I'll say, you know,
Susan and I have had plenty
of fireside chats over
the years, but none in public, so this is
the first time we've done this
and bear with us, all right.
So who knows where it will go, but we hope
it will be instructive.
And I think we'd like to
structure it in a way that
it's a little bit different
than if this were a, you know,
if I were someone like a real interviewer,
someone who does this for a
living who happens, you know,
and because I'm her brother, hopefully,
we can push a little bit
further on some issues
if she'll let me, get a
little bit more personal.
And hopefully, we'll keep it professional.
- And hopefully, we'll
still like each other
when we're done.
- Right, so...
(audience laughter)
So the way we're gonna structure this
in terms of the fireside
chat, before we open it up
for questions from you all,
is we'll talk a little bit
about the core here, you
know, sort of foreign policy
which is, you know, you're
living and breathing every day.
And then I think we'd like to broaden it
and talk more generally
about issues that I think,
that I know that Susan
cares about that cut across,
they may incorporate foreign policy,
but they may be focused on other issues
that she thinks are important.
I wanna hear her thoughts
on those (mumbles)
a few themes there.
And then we wanna give you more personal
and give you all a sense
of what makes her tick.
And hopefully, to share some
advice and perspective from
the, you know, the
experiences that she's had.
So that's gonna be the
approach, and obviously,
we'll open it up for questions
and we can go anywhere with
those questions as well.
Is that okay, Susan?
- No.
- No, all right.
- It is what it is, go ahead.
- You might wanna pour
some water there too.
This is something she'd
never done, she's never,
you know, pouring some water for me to--
(audience laughter)
But that's actually not
true, she's a great cook.
And she'd had us over for
dinner on Sunday night
and did a fantastic
job, so appreciate that.
(audience laughter)
So let's start foreign policy.
We know that she has a high
pressure job, and to say
the least, one of the
highest pressure cooker jobs
I think in the world.
And so my first question
really is, you know, when,
describe a time where you
have been the most nervous.
When you worried the most about having to
go do something before you did it.
- This is gonna sound
strange to some of you,
but the work I do every day in my job
is work that I feel
relatively comfortable with
and I've been doing it for
the better part of my career.
And I may stress about
issues or stress about
how a particular event or
trip or visit may come out,
but that's very normal,
manageable stress for me.
The most stressed I've ever been in life,
in all honesty, was
when I had to throw out
the opening pitch at the
Nationals game in 2013.
I had just taken my job as
national security advisor
that month, I am a decent
athlete, but I have
no particular skill at baseball.
And I was determined to
throw it from the mound
and at least wanted to get
it across in the vicinity
of the plate, to the plate,
at least the distance.
And I was practicing
for weeks, really, and
I was lucky enough that some of the guys
on my security detail were
willing to throw with me.
So we'd go out, we'd throw a
few on a Saturday or Sunday.
And the transition occurred
right as I left my job
at the UN and was coming
over to the White House,
and my security detail switch
from diplomatic security
that helped me, took care of
me when I was a UN ambassador,
to Secret Service, and my
lead agent on Secret Service,
who was determined that I was
not gonna humiliate everybody
at the plate.
And so he was kind enough to
throw with me in the tunnel
right before I went out on the field,
and I had to go out and I was struck by
how fast it all happened, you get there
and they say okay, go to the mound.
And you, 50,000 people are watching you
and you're either gonna get
it or you're not gonna get it.
And you can imagine that, you
know, I've been the subject
of a little bit of public
criticism on occasion.
And I could just see Fox
News, you know, doing a loop
on me grounding the ball, you know, so
I got a pair and there was
no time and they said okay,
Susan Rice, the national security advisor.
Johnny was there, and
it was mostly cheers,
but there were some audible boos.
- Yeah, there were, there were.
- And I just had to throw.
And I wound up and threw
it and I threw a strike
across the plate.
And my heart rate went from probably 190
back down to something like 70 and--
- What would your boss have said--
- Yeah, exactly, the president
would've ragged on me until,
you know, there was no end.
He had done the same, and of course,
managed to throw a pitch, so
he would've talked about me.
And then I was worried, frankly,
on behalf of all womenkind.
(audience laughter)
That, you know, if I let the side down,
that it would've been
terrible, so that was stress
of a sort I was not accustomed to
and I'm never ever doing it again.
(audience laughter)
- Not the answer I was
expecting, that's fantastic.
So let's talk about Syria, let's switch it
a little bit here, all right.
(audience laughter)
- Well, that stresses me out too.
- All right.
So I know you share with
me like the how, you know,
this is maybe the most
complicated foreign policy issue
that you've had to deal with
intellectually in your career.
In part because, you know,
it seems like there are,
you know, almost nothing but bad options
that cascade into another, you know,
set of worse options and even
worse scenarios and so forth,
so you know, the first question,
is there any path to a political solution
and is there any way that
we can mitigate or alleviate
this humanitarian crisis
that's coming out of there?
- Well, honestly, I do
think the crisis in Syria
is the hardest problem to
solve that I've encountered.
And I felt that way
from the very beginning
four and a half years ago.
And it's only getting
harder, there's no question.
I do think there is a path
to a political solution
and we're working very hard towards that
as we have for quite a
while, but as the dynamics
have changed and the
circumstances have evolved,
in some ways, the path is more fraught
when you consider that this
is now a multi-front conflict.
It's the opposition against Assad,
Assad against the
opposition and his people.
It's ISIL and Al-Nusra,
the Al-Qaeda affiliate,
against both of those sides.
And it's the world
against ISIL and Al-Nusra.
So it is a mashup, if
there is such a thing,
on the battlefield.
And the only way this gets resolved
is through a political
solution, there's no other way.
I mean, you could have local
ceasefires conceivably,
we have periodic success
in humanitarian access.
But to deal with the
primary concern we have,
which is defeating ISIL and
ensuring that the threat
that that very pernicious
terrorist organization poses
is not exacerbated and
doesn't reach our shores
is our primary focus.
But to accomplish that,
obviously, we also have to deal
with the fundamental underlying conflict,
which is a civil conflict, which has taken
an extraordinary humanitarian toll,
and we obviously have a great interest
in alleviating the suffering.
And that war can only end
at the negotiating table,
that's gonna require a
resolution not, frankly,
dissimilar from what was
envisioned back in Geneva
in 2012 when we were part of a negotiation
that established a
framework that envisioned
a transitional governing
authority, agreed by mutual consent
between the opposition and the government.
And the theory of that was, if there had
to be mutual consent, there
couldn't be the perpetuation
of Assad's leadership in a regime
that had lost all
legitimacy with its people,
there would have to be other elements
from the existing government
that had less blood
on its hands in practice,
elements of the opposition
who are capable of bringing expertise
to a transitional governing body,
and then a period of transition,
time to be determined,
during which a new constitution
could be written, elections
could be organized, a ceasefire
implemented, et cetera.
That still remains fundamentally
the likeliest outcome when eventually
we get to a political solution,
we are trying very hard to accelerate
the achievement of the political solution,
and Secretary Kerry last
week met in Vienna with
the foreign ministers of Turkey
and Saudi Arabia and Russia,
who are key players, obviously, in this.
And he will meet again, in what I expect
will be just several days'
time, with that group
and then a broader group
of countries in the region
with the aim of trying to operationalize
some kind of political
transition and ceasefire.
The big thorny issue that remains is when
and whether Assad steps aside.
Our view remains that he has to go,
that there can't be an
end to this conflict
which has taken so many lives
and caused so much suffering
and the, you know, displacement
of over four million people,
without him departing as
part of the transition.
But at what stage of the transition
is something that is being
discussed and debated,
we have very different views
than our coalition partners do
from the Syrian government,
the Russians and the Iranians.
But I think there is the potential
for an arrangement to be agreed
wherein this transition
begins, perhaps with Assad
still in power, but it
doesn't end with him in power.
And when, along that
continuum, the transition
and his removal occurs
is the hardest issue.
The other challenge is,
frankly, that the opposition
is extraordinarily fragmented and there is
no single group or leaders
that speaks for those
that have been fighting Assad.
And now the opposition, there
is what we believe to be
our call and work with
the moderate opposition,
but they are sometimes co-mingled
with the extremist
opposition, including elements
like Al-Nusra or those
affiliated with Al-Nusra.
The only thing that most people,
I would say almost everybody agrees with,
is that ISIL is a problem
that can only dealt with
directly and confrontationally,
and so the aim is
to get this political
solution as soon as possible
and turn our collective
efforts without the distraction
of this ongoing civil
conflict against ISIL.
And we haven't talked
about Iraq, but obviously,
that's very much part of the same hole.
- All right, so it's incredibly
complicated, and if we,
so for those of us who
are not in there with you
and the president, Secretary
Kerry and your teams,
thinking through these issues, you know,
I've always been curious
sort of, you know,
what principles, human
principles you kind of pull from
and where there's, you know,
beyond the issues here,
is there anything that those of us
who are not in your world can glean about
sort of what principles to draw upon
when you're dealing with a situation
where there are no good
options and you have to decide
among options that are, you know, just,
where you don't have a
positive set of options?
And I'm wondering, you
know, is there anything
that we can learn from, again,
outside of foreign policy
in our own lives?
Any thought you'd have on what
principles that, you know,
what you've learned, what
principles we can draw upon
that are relevant to our
lives outside of your work?
- I'm not sure if the lessons
are directly applicable.
And in the world of foreign
policy and national security,
at the risk of oversimplifying, you know,
the first question or the first principle
that we have to wrestle
with is, quite frankly,
what is in the United
States national interests?
And that may be different,
the answer to that question,
very ruthlessly defined,
may be not as edifying
as we might wanna believe.
It is in the United States'
national interests, for example,
in Syria, to get deeply
involved in the conflict
on the ground in a combat role.
Well, we've seen the consequences
of the conflict continuing, they are
deeply insidious consequences
that have horrific outcomes
for the people of Syria,
are destabilizing, giving
the refugee outflow to
the neighbors, you're now
having implications, with
the refugee flow, for Europe.
And now we have the challenge of ISIL,
which does directly threaten
threaten our interests
and that of our allies and partners.
But we may have to tailor our solutions
more narrowly to the
challenge of defeating ISIL
than to the broader
challenges that are important,
that we care about, but are not
the ones we must prioritize.
At the same time, we can
alleviate humanitarian suffering,
we are the largest contributor
the humanitarian response
with over 4.5 billion dollars.
But you know, as human beings,
we all want to do what is,
you know, the right
thing on a human level.
And sometimes, I would
argue even oftentimes,
what is right on a human
level is also what most
or best serves US interests,
but it's not 100% coincidence,
and sometimes the hardest choices are
when those things can't
be readily reconciled.
Now, translating that into,
you know, daily life is hard.
I mean, when you face circumstances where,
in your personal and professional life,
you have no good answers and
no good options, you know,
I think that, I don't know
that I can say, you know,
take this lesson from the situation room
and apply it somewhere else.
But I think, one thing
I'd say is, you know,
when you examine your options,
you have to ask not only
what will be the effect
of a particular action,
but you also have to ask what would be
the effect of inaction and weigh those
and try to anticipate the
consequences of your actions,
you know, three or four
steps down the road.
Because what may be the most immediate,
least bad answer today could prove
to be worse down the road.
- [John] Down the road, yeah.
- And I suppose vice versa.
So in trying to play out
almost as if a chess game,
the actions and reactions, is I guess
the best analogy I can draw.
- [John] That's helpful, that's helpful.
- But it's hard to make
a direct connection.
- I think that's instructive.
And so stepping back a little bit, I mean,
you've been on, you've been a core member
of the president's foreign
policy team from the beginning,
right, you started up
at the UN and now down
at the White House.
And I assume you're gonna
stay till the end, okay,
I haven't heard otherwise.
And so I wanna ask you now, you know,
if you kinda reflect back (mumbles)
a lot has been accomplished, you know,
what are you most proud of
when you think about a couple,
you know, if you wanna
mention a few milestones
or a few accomplishments
that you're most proud of
that you weren't sure you could get done
when you joined the team back
actually on the campaign,
and when the president was sworn in?
What are you most proud of to date?
- Well, with the caveat that
that which I'm most proud of
doesn't mean that I had a direct hand
in accomplishing all of them.
And I think vitally important from
a national security point
of view was the success
that our economic team had early on
in turning around their economy.
Because a huge source of
our international strength
is the strength of our
economy domestically
and whether we're able to grow
and produce wealth and jobs,
and when the president
came into office, we were,
as you well recall, at the lowest point
since the Great Depression.
And now, after years,
we are back to a place
of economic leadership in the world,
and the rest of the world
has certainly made progress,
but you know, the economies
in various different parts
of the world are still relatively soft,
we are now not impervious, obviously,
but the strongest link, and
that has been fundamental
in restoring our leadership abroad.
But beyond that, obviously, I mean,
we've tried to focus on a
number of things, first of all,
despite the challenges that
still remain in Afghanistan
and Iraq, when President
Obama came into office,
we had 180,000 troops in both theaters.
We are down to less than
10,000 in Afghanistan today.
We'll be going down to 5500
by the end of next year.
And we're about 3300 in Iraq.
And very narrowly tailored missions
to supporting the Iraqis and the Afghans
by training and advising
and assisting them,
we're not in combat in either
theater directly anymore.
And we're also engaged
in counter terrorism
in a targeted way.
I think, you know, the
fact that we've been able
to redeploy and rebalance
and refresh our armed forces
is vitally important to our readiness
and our ongoing strength,
even as the nature
of challenges has evolved.
But I'm particularly pleased that,
when you look around the
world, we're rebalancing
to Asia and the Asia Pacific.
A great deal of our time and energy
that doesn't get a lot
of attention in the press
is devoted to the work that
we're doing in the Asia Pacific.
We have just had, over
the last several months,
high profile and very impactful visits
from the Japanese leader,
the Chinese leader,
the South Korean leader just this week,
the Indonesian leader.
We are heading to Asia next month, again,
we have gone, if not every
year, then twice every year,
in the recent past, for very important
summit meetings out there.
And we've just been able to conclude
the Trans-Pacific
Partnership trade agreement,
which is a signature element
of the Asia rebalance,
so I think that's something that will be
of lasting significance.
We've all worked very hard on
the issue of non-proliferation
and trying to reduce
the threat from loose,
what some people call loose nukes,
which is not the term we're
supposed to use, but you know,
we have strengthened nuclear security
in a very meaningful
way, and then, of course,
we've been able to reach the agreement to
prevent Iran from
obtaining a nuclear weapon
with the support of the
international community.
And I think that will
prove, if fully implemented,
to have been an unexpected
and yet very meaningful means
of constraining a very
dangerous nuclear program
and ensuring that Iran is not able
to obtain a nuclear weapon.
So that's another thing, I think frankly,
when we look back on our time,
I certainly will be very pleased
that we've made an opening with Cuba
and that 50 years of failed
policy have been supplanted
by what I think will
prove over the long term
to be the most effective
means of opening up Cuba,
both politically and economically.
And finally, and I could
go on, but you know,
as a policy maker, but also
as a mother and as a citizen,
you know, one of the issues
that I'm most concerned about,
and I know the president has
put the highest priority on,
is climate change and trying
to address that threat.
And we are now heading
into Paris in December
for the COP meeting on climate change
with the real potential
of achieving an agreement
that will ratchet down
emissions in a meaningful way,
and we've been able to negotiate
with China, the largest,
we're the first and the
second largest emitters
of greenhouse gases, an
unprecedented mutual commitment
to reduce our carbon output.
And that has set the
stage for us to be able
to gain commitments from countries
amounting to 80%, 85% now of
emissions around the world
to make very concrete national commitments
to reduce their emission, so
if we can get this agreement
in Paris and if it is
meaningful and substantive,
that will be a huge step, and the steps
we've taken domestically to reinforce that
are a critical part as well.
- Got it, so if I could pivot a little bit
just to an area that you
don't get to talk too much,
at least so much about
publicly, and I think, you know,
but I know you well enough to know
that you are passionate about some things
that go beyond foreign policy.
- [Susan] You think?
- Right.
And they're things that are
important to our nation,
and one of the things that
you share with me, Susan,
you know, is your passion for
sort of the improving equality
of opportunity in this
nation and globally.
And so when you think about
hot button issues that are like
criminal justice reform and
policing and immigration
and healthcare, K through
12 education, gay marriage,
I mean, so many of them
relate to this, you know,
are related to the issue
of equality of opportunity.
And some of these issues,
you all really moved
the needle on it, within the context
of the administration,
over the last seven years.
Some are rising to the top now.
But I just, I wanna get your, you know,
your point of view, not
necessarily from the point of the,
you know, the perspective
of the administration, okay,
'cause this is not your lane--
- [Susan] I would not get out of my lane.
- But given that you, you know, we're here
with members of the New Haven community
and students and professors
here at the university
who are ambitious and
idealistic and are tackling
some of these tough issues,
you know, in your mind,
you know, what are the
one or two critical levers
that we should focus on in our nation
to move the needle on
equality of opportunity?
- [Female Speaker] Excuse
me, madam secretary,
I'm taking a small call back
here and we can't hear you.
- [John] Okay.
How do we...
(background noise drowns
out female speaker)
Okay.
- I'm sorry.
- [John] Can't hear it.
- Can you hear better now?
- [Female Speaker] Yes.
- Thank you for saying it,
I wish you'd said it sooner.
Thank you.
- [John] Thank you.
- These are unusual contraptions.
(audience laughter)
- [John] Can you hear me?
Yeah, okay, sorry.
- So repeat the question.
- So the question is, when
you think about, you know,
addressing, you know, inequality here,
inequality of opportunity in this nation,
and you can speak globally if you'd like.
You know, if you, you know, if
you were, folks in the crowd,
if you, you know, what should we,
what can we move the needle on,
what are the things, the levers,
that we should be focusing
on to build a nation
that really addresses and moves the needle
on equality of opportunity?
- Well, I mean, Johnny, I think you know,
this is something I cared deeply about,
but it's not an area that I'm expert in.
I think, you heard from the
introduction of my background,
and Johnny's, I call
him Johnny, by the way.
Some people call him John.
That we've taken very
different career paths.
But we grew up in the same
household with the same values
and the same parents and the same,
many of the same, I think,
motivations and concerns.
And I think this is an
area that has united us,
John's work is really
about building ladders
for those who have not had necessarily
all of the privilege and
opportunity that has been,
that we've been blessed with
and that many are blessed with,
so that they have the
mentorship and the preparation
and the training to go
into high powered careers
and opportunities in
business or management
or the non-profit world, but
the theory of John's non-profit
is that, if you catch
a young person early on
and give him or her, with
all of their inherent talent,
the opportunities, the
mentorship, the training,
the support to succeed,
then the likelihood
of their success goes way up.
And my own personal passion
that, as Johnny said,
is not the focus of my workday today,
but it is fundamentally
an animating motivation,
is I believe deeply, as many of us do,
in the fundamental worth and
equality of every human being.
And I believe fundamentally,
and this may be part
of my experience as an
African American woman,
that there is so much
more talent out there
than ever is able to rise to the surface,
and that we have not only an
obligation and an interest
in nurturing and cultivating
that talent, but that,
as a matter of national
strength and even, indeed,
security, to the extent
that we are not cultivating
and nurturing that talent,
wherever it may reside, we are diminished,
we are not firing on all cylinders,
we're competing with one
hand tied behind our back.
And so I believe passionately
that we can do better
and we have to do better.
And that, I think, frankly boils down to
what you all would assume
and that is sort of obvious,
which is education.
And starting at the earliest
stages, at, you know,
early education, preschool,
and all the way up
through higher education, being
able to provide young people
with the support that
they need and deserve,
and that means that education
has to be affordable,
it has to be of a decent
quality, it has to be safe
and it has to be available
to kids whether they come
from inner city New
Haven or from, you know,
the wealthiest suburbs elsewhere.
And frankly, we still have
not done, in my judgment,
as a nation, a sufficient job
of focusing on that deficit
and investing in the talent
that this nation has,
and we are one of the most skilled,
diverse, rich societies in the world.
And when I look out internationally
and I think, you know,
how do we sustain American leadership
through the 21st century and
beyond, how do we maximize
our inherent strength, and I don't mean
just our military strength or
even our economic strength,
but our social and our
intellectual strength
and our cultural strength.
It necessitates that we take advantage of
this extraordinary fabric
that is our talented
and diverse society, and if we
are not doing that adequately, not only
are we leaving behind so many,
but I really truly believe
we are not doing our, we're not fulfilling
our potential as a global leader.
- Great, great.
So getting more personal, okay.
- We haven't gotten personal yet.
You and I, we can get real personal.
- All right, so you're
a mom of two, right,
you have a seventh grader
and you have a son,
seventh grade daughter,
Maris, son in high school
who's actually accompanied you here, Jake.
And you're a wife of 23
years, is that right?
How many, how many years, okay.
And you spend a lot of time, I mean,
and I've been so impressed
by how you've been able
to spend so much time over the course
of the last eight years
caring for our father,
our mom now, you know, and
finding time to do that.
So this is not a question
about work-life balance,
'cause I know that's not,
you know, even a, you know,
part of a vocabulary here.
But I wanted to see if
you have any, you know,
guiding principles around
that you could share
with the audience here about
how to stay above water
and not let the most important balls drop.
How do you approach it,
how do you, knowing that
it's not perfect, knowing
that you've gotta make
tough trade offs in your personal life.
You've kept the most important,
I can attest to that
personally, I really admire
how you figured out how to do that.
And it comes with trade
offs, but any, you know,
what advice would you
have for the folks here,
whether they're undergrad,
grad students here
or folks who are not
students here, on how to keep
the most important balls
from dropping when you're--
- Well, let me, first
of all, I'm not trying
to blow smoke here,
but Johnny is giving me
a lot of credit, and the
fact is, we have, well,
we've been blessed with
two wonderful parents,
our father passed away
four and a half years ago,
our mom is still alive, she,
I think, would've enjoyed
being here today, she's in Washington
and her health is fragile.
And we have, together, I
think, done a pretty good job
of trying to support our parents.
And we've succeeded because
we've done it together,
along with my husband and
Johnny's wife and our kids.
And the answer to your
question is because, you know,
this is teamwork, no one
individual can manage, you know,
the challenges of taking care of kids,
taking care of family,
taking care of yourself.
It does require partners.
- [John] So marry well, that's
your advice, marry well?
- Definitely marry well.
Yeah, I've been extraordinarily
blessed to have this,
the most wonderful,
supportive and, you know,
talented husband, you have,
you've done very well yourself.
(audience laughter)
And fortunately, everybody
likes each other,
so we really, we have been a team.
But if I had some advice,
I'd say the following.
First of all, everybody is
different, every circumstance
is different, and I hate
these conversations where,
you know, women debate,
where they lean in, lean out,
you know, tell everybody
how to handle their lives.
My view on this is
everybody's life is different,
everybody's circumstance is
different, people really need
to stop telling each other what to do
and just support each other and recognize
that everybody is trying to
make the best choices they can
in their particular circumstances
and there's no one size fits all formula.
The only thing I can say
from my vantage point
that has been a valuable principle for me
is that family comes first.
And even in a job like mine,
family comes first, because,
and your dearest friends, because
when everything else falls apart,
that's what you've got left,
you've got the people you love
and the people who love you.
And if you ever forget that, then I think
you're missing something fundamental.
And I just wanna say, I
mean, I've thought a lot
about this in my own life
and I've just seen it modeled
in the most extraordinary
way, having had the privilege
of working very closely
with Vice President Biden
who has just gone through
extraordinary loss.
And in the context of working, you know,
the second toughest job in the world.
And he has been there for his family,
his family has been there for him,
he was there for Beau,
just as he was there
for Beau and Hunter early in their lives
when they suffered extraordinary loss.
And he is living proof that
you can and you must invest
your utmost in your
family, even as you take on
the most challenging
responsibilities that you might find,
whether in government
or the private sector
or the non-profit world.
So you know, there have been
times in my professional life
and personal life where it's, you know,
we've hit very painful patches.
But what has made it all
sustainable and worthwhile
is that we've had each other and we've had
our extended family and
the love and support
of our kids and our
parents and our spouses.
And I think, you know,
it's a simple truism,
but I think sometimes,
in the rush and the press
of professional life and stress,
that can sometimes be
forgotten, and it shouldn't be.
- All right, so before we
open it up for questions,
I have one last one and it
builds upon what you said,
and it speaks to, you know, you've had a,
quite a rollercoaster ride, right,
over the course of the last few years.
I mean, you had a great run at the UN,
felt like you got a lot done there.
Benghazi came up and that got politicized.
The whole secretary of state stuff.
And now what you talked
about, some of the things
that you've really been excited about
over the course of your tenure here
as a national security advisor.
So there are probably
lots of people here today
whose parents are worrying how
they will handle adversity
when it comes up.
How do, you know, and handle setbacks,
because so many folks here up at Yale
haven't had big setbacks yet.
And these are, this
could be a new frontier
because you've had so much
success in your lives to date,
and I'm wondering, you know,
what advice would you have
for these folks about what you draw on
when you have setbacks, when
you have adversity, you know,
when that comes, where do you draw on?
Do you draw from family?
You know, what do you do,
even when, especially in times
where you feel like, you know,
you may or may not have done anything
to bring that adversity on yourself.
And that's a tough question,
it's a personal question,
but anything you would
share with the group
about how to deal with
adversity when it comes?
- Well, I think the first
answer is the answer
I already gave, which is
that, family and friends
and the strength that they provide.
But I think also, the strength
has gotta come from inside.
And now just speaking very
very personally, I have,
for better or for worse,
I've always known who I am,
I've always known what I believe,
I've always tried to do what
I do with the utmost integrity
and intensity and I
believe that, you know,
I know who I am and I
also know who I'm not.
And when I'm watching a
caricature or a critique of myself
that is painful and
personalized, I'm able to,
I don't wanna suggest
that I don't feel the,
I don't feel offended or I don't feel hurt
in some instances by it, but
I'm also able to distinguish
between what I know about myself
and who I know myself to
be and what is being said.
And there, to the extent
that I'm able to understand
and maintain that distinction,
I can keep a certain distance from it.
What's harder, and I'll tell you that,
and you know this, but I'll
just acknowledge it here.
The hardest thing for me,
going through the period
you described in 2012, was
not what it felt like for me.
The hardest thing was what I saw it do
to my mom and to my daughter who were
in very different ways,
in different, I mean,
what was, Maris was--
- [John] Fifth grade, yeah, 11 to 12?
- No, she's 12 now.
(laughs)
She was nine.
It really hit her very very hard.
She was old enough to
be able to understand
that her mom is being
vilified on the television
and hear the things that were being said
and sort of understand
why it was happening,
but not really understand
that it, what you see
isn't necessarily all that
there is to the story.
And it was, it really was briefly
but intensely destabilizing for her.
And then my mom, who's tough as nails
but has an addiction to cable news,
just couldn't turn the television off,
but also, it was driving
her absolutely insane.
And this after she'd just
come out of the hospital
and been through, you know, surgery
and very difficult recovery
and all this stuff.
And you know, she just was beside herself.
And it was the only
time that I was really,
I hate to say this, but I
was glad dad wasn't alive.
'Cause if dad had been alive,
he would've taken his shotgun
up to Capitol Hill and it
would've been all over.
- [John] Grew up in South
Carolina, all right, (mumbles).
- You know, you just, the
other thing I'd say is
that you keep working and you
keep doing what you believe.
And in some ways, it was great
to be at the UN at the time,
where the issues that we were working on
and that my fellow ambassadors cared about
were far removed from
the noise in Washington.
It never, it was incredible
to me that, as UN ambassador,
I would have to go
before the UN press corps
multiple times a week and make
statements or take questions,
and never once, at the UN,
got asked about Benghazi
because they didn't care, it was,
they saw it as a
manufactured political story
and they wanted to ask about
the issues on the UN agenda.
Come to Washington, it's
a little bit different.
- A little different, yeah, got it.
Okay, let's open it up.
Yeah, why don't you come on up,
as you will be a much more
capable moderator than I.
So how do wanna run this?
- She's running it.
- So first, I just wanna make
sure we give a large round
of applause to Ambassador
Rice and John Rice.
(applause)
- And I wanna thank
Johnny, but encourage him
to keep his day job.
(audience laughter)
You did a great job.
- So I am the moderator
of this Q&A session,
and I may need to moderate
up here as well, as I see.
Oh, there was a friendly
handshake that just happened.
I am the master of Timothy Dwight College,
I'm Mary Lui and it's
a real pleasure for me
to greet all of you and certainly welcome
our two wonderful guests who
shared with us their remarks
and they covered so much
ground in their fireside chat,
so I think there's gonna
be numerous opportunities
to ask questions to follow up.
I also wanna take the time really quickly
to thank President Salovey
for his introductory remarks,
thank you for that.
So we are gonna open up
for questions right now,
so please go ahead and line up,
either two microphones right here,
and just be in a very orderly fashion.
And we'll alternate between
the two microphones.
I'm seeing two very large lines forming,
and we will not able to get
through all of the questions,
I already am apologizing
to the people in the back.
So I will just say, once
you ask your question,
please step aside from the microphone
and let's let our
wonderful guests respond.
So let's start on this side.
- [Male Speaker] Hi, I live in Ukraine,
have done so for the past 25 years.
I'd like to ask you your view
on the situation in Ukraine
with reference to two
things in particular.
First, do the violations
of the Budapest Treaty
fundamentally undermine
nuclear non-proliferation
for the future?
And second, the US with
Japan, which I believe
would be favorable to this, I
know it would be, and the EU,
helped to get the world buying some MIGA
political risk insurance
program going for Ukraine again,
so that there are gonna be investment
from the rest of the world.
You've done a fine job with
OPIC, but a lot of the world
that was investing in Ukraine has stopped
and it's produced a catastrophic
25% decline in the GDP.
And this wasn't caused by Ukraine,
it was caused by Ukraine's reliance
on the security assurances
of the Budapest Treaty,
based on which we gave
up 5000 nuclear weapons.
So can the United States help with this?
- Well, certainly, we
can and we are working
to help Ukraine in many different ways,
with its economic
recovery, just yesterday,
I was saying we are
working to help Ukraine
in various ways, including
with its economic recovery.
Just yesterday in Kiev,
we announced the third
one billion dollar US
government loan guarantee
for the government in
Kiev, we are providing
technical assistance, we're
providing military aid,
we're providing various forms of security
and economic support to the government,
and the loan guarantees, of course,
are not the sum total of
our economic assistance,
but they're part and parcel,
we've also been very active
with Europe and the international
financial institutions
to try to provide the support
that Ukraine is now receiving
through the international
financial institutions.
So we are very much trying to support
economic recovery in
Ukraine and its independence
from its former dependence
on Russia and the East.
So there is, there have
been some creative ideas
and you may be referring
to some of the ideas
that George Soros has talked about.
- [Male Speaker] Correct.
- And these are ones that we
have looked at very carefully,
I've spoken myself to
Mr. Soros about this,
as have many of my colleagues,
including Secretary Liu.
His idea relies on a mechanism
within the European Union
and their ability to activate a mechanism
that could leverage additional
funds, and unfortunately,
there are a number of
complexities with it,
but the principal one
being that the Europeans
have not been interested
in pursuing that option.
- [Male Speaker] Yes, his way of doing it
is not the only way, there are other ways.
And as a lawyer in the private
sector there for 25 years,
we have a lot of clients
that would like to come in
and make a contribution to the economy,
the private sector has been forgotten.
He is correct, without
political risk insurance,
when it gets to board approval
level, companies are afraid,
with that, they will go forward with plans
they would like to implement.
And I personally have
actually, my law firm,
a couple of billion dollars of investment
that is presently frozen
that could be unblocked
with political risk
insurance at the MIGA level,
as has been done for
the West Bank and Gaza.
That would work, Soros'
mechanism probably doesn't.
- Well, I appreciate that and
I'll look into it, thank you.
- [Male Speaker] Thank you.
- [Mary] Yes, this gentleman here.
- [Male Speaker] Thank you,
Ambassador Rice, and brother.
- You can call him Johnny.
- [Male Speaker] It was
very interesting to hear
the personal side, to know that,
behind that very informidable
government figure
that you are, that there
is a very personal side,
that's very important.
I just want to, my question
has to do with Syria,
but very quickly regarding
this gentleman, Ukraine.
We represent a consortium of
students all over the world
and many of them are in
Ukraine, and they asked me
to ask you one question or
to let you know one thing,
and that they are very
concerned about the fact
that the general prosecutor
in Ukraine, they feel,
is corrupt and is not really doing,
making any progress in
terms of judicial reform,
in terms of really reforming
the judiciary and reforming,
and getting rid of a lot
of government figures,
and this is what they feel
and they are just wondering
if the United States could exert
some kind of leverage or
at least look into the fact
that this general prosecutor is very much
not on the side of the Ukraine citizenry?
But my main question has to do with Syria,
and what I consider is not a
no fly zone, but a buffer zone.
And the fact that we also
deal with Russian students,
and they all seem to feel
that the Russian government
might be very amenable to considering
the establishment of a
buffer zone so that refugees,
instead of having to
cross the Mediterranean,
could rest or be settled in
this zone with, obviously,
there's a lot of, you know,
there's a lot of problems
with that, I realize, there's cost
and then there's possibility of conflict,
but if the Russian government
is willing to support this,
and they feel it will
because the refugees,
a lot of these refugees or
a lot of these terrorists,
a lot of jihadists could
be part of the refugees
and going back to Russia.
So that I'm wondering why
the United States government
has not pursued, or at
least outwardly pursued
the establishment more of
a buffer zone in Syria?
Thank you very much.
- Well, thank you for the
question, it's a topical one.
We have, at various
points during the course
of the crisis in Syria, weighed the merits
and risks of various forms of
zones, as we shorthand them,
no fly zones, safe zones on the ground
where civilians could be protected,
I think that's what you mean.
And then we've also looked at something
that we've termed a buffer zone,
which is not necessarily a safe zone
with protection for
civilians on the ground,
but some zone meant to be a bulwark
so that people and weapons
and other malicious flows
of goods and the like
can't continue to occur.
In all honesty, these are options
that we continue to examine.
We have not ruled out any of them
in a formal or permanent
way, but we've looked at them
very very closely including,
again, very recently.
And they are fraught with real
challenges and difficulties.
They are incredibly resource
intensive to secure,
so take your model of, let
me call it a safe zone,
on let's say the northern or
southern border within Syria,
either abutting Turkey
or abutting Jordan where,
theoretically, civilians
might be protected.
To enforce a safe zone effectively,
you not only need planes in
the air, and the planes in
the air are complicated because
the threat that most of the,
the most proximate danger
to civilians is, in fact,
not fixed wing aircraft, it's helicopters
dropping barrel bombs that are harder
to deal with in the context of an air cap.
And then it's on the ground where you need
literally tens of thousands of troops
to hold and clear that territory.
Where those troops would come from,
whether weighing our
interests, you would use
our air power and our
forces to protect folks
on the ground and clearing out territory
or whether you would use
them to go after ISIL
because they are not the same mission
is one of the tricky questions
that policy makers have to weigh.
A trade off where, if we were
to employ additional resources,
would they best be utilized?
A humanitarian mission, which
is the one you're describing,
is not the same as a counter ISIL mission
in the current context.
There may be a point when they align,
but they don't at the moment.
And then you have the
question of to what extent
does that actually improve
conditions on the ground?
The major border crossings
are open to humanitarian aid,
the aid is flowing, so particularly into
the areas near the border
that we're talking about.
So the incremental benefit to civilians
our actual humanitarian experts
do not think is very significant.
And there's a real question as to whether
the establishment of these zones
would draw people back in or
actually cause them to flee
for fear that they're gonna
be trapped in these zones
where they'd rather have
freedom of movement,
internally or externally.
So there's a huge number
of complexities associated
with this, which is not
to say these are options
that are off the table, but
we are digging into them
very deeply, and they are not as simple
and obvious solutions as you
might hear by turning on,
you know, CNN and listening to
what the pundits are saying.
- [Mary] Thank you, and over here.
- [Female Speaker] Hi,
sorry, I have laryngitis
but I didn't wanna pass
up this opportunity
to ask you a question, it
may be for both of you.
One is, as a woman of
color, you're constantly
in international settings where
you are maybe the only
woman in the room or
the only African American in the room,
or well (background noise
drowns out speaker) but--
(audience laughter)
- Not always, but often.
- [Female Speaker] I was just wondering
how you handle yourself
in those situations
where you might find sexism or some type
of discrimination against
you because of who you are.
And the other part of my question is,
I teach at an inner city
high school here in New Haven
at Hillhouse and it may be
more towards you, Johnny.
What do you think we can
do at the local level
to help our kids to like
experience things like this,
to expose them to international,
because they think very small,
they think very locally.
And to get them to think
more outside of New Haven
or their particular
situations and contribute,
like you were talking about at the end,
about there are so many
resources that we don't have,
for whatever reason, that
America might be losing out
on the potential that we have.
And who knows, you know, maybe the person
who has a cure for cancer
is a high school student
in Hillhouse, but they may not have
the same opportunities that others have.
So if you could address that, and then--
- Okay, could you all hear the question?
So one was directed to me and
one was directed to Johnny.
The one directed to me was, and I hope
I don't do it misjustice, but essentially,
as an African American
woman finding herself
in various international settings,
how do I deal with some,
being the only one or being
certainly one of the few?
And have I faced, you know,
discrimination and the like?
I think the answer is,
you know, obviously,
there are some
circumstances where I may be
the only woman in the room
or the only person of color.
But I'm representing the
United States of America.
And I have found that, when I show up
in whatever role I'm
in, even when I was in
far more junior roles, as a representative
of the United States of America,
people primarily dealt
with me on that basis.
And I can't pretend that there
haven't been occasions when,
you know, people have made
flip comments or, you know,
been somewhat condescending,
but for the most part,
they don't have the space or the ability
to do that or to dwell
on it because they know,
at the end of the day,
that they have to deal,
for better or for worse, with whatever
the United States government
is coming or saying or doing.
And that's the basis on which I have found
that I'm interacting on
most, if not all occasions.
And so I, to a great
extent, have not found that
to be an impediment.
Far more of an impediment, frankly,
but still overwritten by this
fact that I was representing
the US government, was
when I was 32 years old
and the assistant secretary
of state for African affairs,
and often the senior American
official going around
representing the United
States, and it was my youth
rather than my gender or my
race that was most noticed.
And still not something
that, at the end of the day,
got in the way of my doing my job.
- I quickly say, relative to Hillhouse.
Sure, you know, the easy answer
is to expose your students
to what's happening over
here at Yale, then get them
over here, invite them to
things like this and so forth.
I think that's part of it, I'm
sure we can do more of that.
But I also think the tougher
thing and the thing we need
to do more of is take Yale over
to them and meet them where they are.
You know, I just, coincidentally,
when I was a student here,
I started a, you know,
I got my first exposure
to kind of, my first bug and
excitement around mentoring
and the social sector, I
actually started a program
over at Hillhouse High School,
this was back in the 80s,
that was called the Young
Men's Leadership Forum,
and we took, we brought
a bunch of Yale students
over to Hillhouse every week
and we did study skills,
mentoring, we did, you know,
a lot of work on the ground
in the classrooms with those students
and just to provide, most of
whom were teenage fathers,
okay, and we just met them
where they were and we helped
and we built relationships.
And we were there, you
know, in their house.
Now, I think that really
made the difference.
And the other thing we did,
which is sort of that I think
you could argue is the kind
of thing we could do more of,
but just as a fun entrepreneurial thing,
you know, for those of you who don't know,
at least back then, Hillhouse had
a great basketball tradition.
And they would, when they
would play Wilbur Cross here,
they would have more
people in Payne Whitney Gym
than we would have when we were playing
at the Yale basketball team.
And so they thought they were
really good at basketball,
so I brought (mumbles), I was
in the basketball team here,
we went over to Hillhouse
and played, and brought,
you know, when we were
seniors, played a game
in their gym, Yale varsity
basketball versus them.
And we had them introduce
it, you know, speak to,
we had speakers, it was
just a fantastic sort of
community event and
built a lot of bridges.
Things like that, I mean,
that's way, you know,
many many years ago.
But it's just an example of things
that we can do more of and
I'm sure we're doing a lot of,
much already, that Peter could speak to,
but filtering out ways to
bring the best of Yale to them
in addition to thinking about exposure
around them coming to us.
- [Mary] Great, so who won the game?
- We killed them.
(audience laughter)
- [Mary] Are there actual witnesses?
- Yes, we killed them, and yes, there are.
So Tim Shriver who's,
you know, the chairman
in Special Olympics, was a
teacher over at Hillhouse then.
And he will attest, he was my partner
in building this initiative
that was very successful.
And not only did we win but
out, wasn't me in this case,
but one of our, one of my teammates
won the dunk contest
against those guys, okay.
So it was an eye opening
moment for Hillhouse students.
(audience laughter)
- [Mary] Yes, over here, please.
- [Male Speaker] So there's
a little over a year left
in President Obama's term,
and I'm just wondering,
looking back and even
a little bit forward,
is there such a thing
as an Obama doctrine,
anything resembling that?
And if that's not
something that's the case,
is there something, is
there a Rice doctrine?
- The Rice doctrine would
have to be the Obama doctrine
for the next 15 months.
No.
You know, we've really
refrained from trying to distill
our approach into a doctrine.
I think if you understand
the way President Obama
approaches foreign policy
and national security.
He is both principled and pragmatic.
And he would reject, as a matter
of intellectual point of
view but also as a matter
of practice, a one size fits all approach.
So no, we don't have a doctrine.
What he would say and
what he deeply believes
is that American leadership is necessary
and indispensable, that
it can be and must be
a force for progress and for good,
but that there are limits to what
even the most powerful
nation on the planet
can accomplish for other
people in their own countries.
And at the end of the day, whether it's
political transformation
or economic growth
or even conflict resolution,
there are vital contributions
that the United States and others
in the international community,
typically with American
leadership, can bring to bear,
but at the end of the day,
there are certain fundamentals
that have to be accomplished by and for
the people of a given
country or a given region,
whether it's fighting
corruption, cronyism,
insisting on respect for human rights,
the outside world can do a
great deal to call attention
and demand certain
standards and performance,
but at the end of the
day, it will not last
and it will not be something
that is fundamentally enduring
unless it is owned by the
local population, and that's,
in many ways, the challenge
we're facing in Syria and Iraq,
it's the challenge we're
facing in Afghanistan,
it's the challenge that you could argue
is at the root of many of the
most difficult global problems
that we are wrestling with.
- [Mary] Jackie.
- [Jackie] Hi, thank you
so much, first of all,
for sharing your insights with us.
Obviously, many of us
are students in the room
and we're figuring out what we want
our priority specialty to be and how,
and if we want those to relate
to our careers after education.
So I was just wondering,
since you hold degrees
in different disciplines,
if you could talk about
the values and interests
that took you from there
to where you are today?
- I wish I could tell you that, you know,
there was a linear path
between, I was a history major.
Johnny studied Latin American studies,
and then I went on and did
international relations.
I don't think so.
My piece of advice, if I
have one, is very simple,
and that's to follow your passion.
Do whatever it is that
motivates you and excites you,
whether you think it's gonna get you
a good job coming out of college or not,
do what you find
fascinating and motivating.
And that's what you're gonna be good at
and that's what will take you to the next
and the next exciting thing.
I never anticipated, when I was
an undergraduate at
Stanford, that I would be
in a career in international affairs,
much less as national security
advisor or UN ambassador.
That was not, I was going to
be a civil rights lawyer or,
you know, a community activist.
That's sort of how I thought of my future,
and if I ever got a home
state that had voting rights
as opposed to the District
of Columbia where I grew up,
I thought maybe I might
run for public office.
And I've ended up in a
completely different place.
But the one thing I have
done is follow my heart
and my head and do
things that I love to do,
and that's never led me astray.
So that's what I would say, Johnny--
- The one thing I'll add to that is,
while you're following your passion,
work really hard at this
stage of your career
to figure out what your genius gifts are,
where you can be top 10,
top 20% in your peer group,
what you do best and
what that translates into
from a career standpoint,
because it's great
to be focused on something
that you love, you know,
if you wanna, you know, I
always share a story (mumbles),
I wanna, you know, I wanna
be a recording artist.
Well, you better be
able to sing, all right,
if you can't sing, I don't
care how passionate you are
about music, you ain't gonna make
any money doing that, right.
So focus on, you know, the combined,
the people who get the farthest,
people who realize their
potential, we found they combine
that sweet spot, that lane, which is
what you're passionate about
and what your, you know,
where your genius gifts are.
Because what you need to focus
on at this stage early on
is being a high performer.
And if you're a high, you're more likely
to be a high performer if you're focusing
on what you're passionate
about, but you're most likely
to be a high performer
if you're really good
at what you're doing.
And being a high performer
will position you
to develop the
relationships that you will,
that will then catapult
your career that I think
everyone here who's more,
you know, tenured there
who could speak to about
how important that is.
- So I'm afraid we're
actually out of time,
I feel very badly for
these, your two lines
that waited so patiently.
Can we please give Ambassador Rice
and John Rice anther round--
(applause)
Thank you.